so here's the road to me watching this
show I actually didn't intend to watch
so I watched the first couple episodes
of Star Wars rebels when they aired I
watched them I was like all right it's
fun family adventures kids stuff didn't
really grab me so I didn't watch it then
the season finale of season 2 came on a
few months ago and I was like you know
what now I'm gonna watch the show anyway
I don't care about spoilers let's see
what all the fuss is about watched it
and I was like holy crap that was
actually really awesome that was badass
and then hence Grand Admiral Thrawn is
gonna be in season 3 then I was like
alright I should probably officially
catch up on Star Wars rebels since I
want to see season 3 and the season
finale of season 2 is actually really
cool but I had to watch Star Wars Clone
Wars first to catch up to the Star Wars
rebels saga because ultimately the two
shows do kind of intertwine didn't
review that because if I had reviewed it
that would be one more video with one
more comment section flooded with you
reviewed this but not stranger things
come on the real reason is Clone Wars is
actually a means to get to rebels but
Clone Wars was actually really cool and
if you're interested in catching up on
Clone Wars which is on Netflix there's
actually a link below to this really
cool diagram that someone made where's
like all right here the episodic
episodes that you can skip and here are
the core story ones that you should
probably watch so now my quest to catch
up on Star Wars rebels I have now seen
Star Wars rebels season 1 so I figured
hey let's talk about it on video because
that's just kind of what I do it's my
thing here
[Music]
Star Wars rebels season one so Star Wars
rebels season one is the beginning of
the Star Wars rebels series which is
definitely getting to season 3 star wars
rebels takes place a few years before a
new hope or if you want to be
forward-thinking a few years before
rogue one it's another way of saying it
it follows this kid named Ezra who
stumbles across this crew of smugglers
one of them is a dude named Canaan Kanan
has a secret Kanan was a Jedi so Ezra
becomes his apprentice all the while
they go on their smuggling adventures
pretty much the gist of most of the
season let me talk about what I liked in
here first most of what I like is
conceptual I like the concept of Canyon
and Ezra because that's just it's a cool
dynamic in this world where Jedi are
extinct you don't know much about Kanan
which I also like I like mystery but you
look at Kanan and this dude is clearly
unqualified to be a Jedi Master he has
no real business training this kid but
it's an imperfect world it's the world
they have Jedi are more or less dead so
this is just this is a scenario we got
we got a deal with that reality this is
an imperfect scenario but what are you
gonna do get on Facebook and find a Jedi
Master no not in this world I know for a
fact Dagobah and Tatooine do not have
social media it's just impossible so I
like that dynamic but again it's
conceptual I like how it started but now
I'm interested to see where it goes
because where it goes in here isn't as
cool and thick as I really wanted it to
be just it's a good introduction and it
is enjoyable to see this crew of
smugglers doing their smuggler missions
knowing that this is the genesis of the
rebellion really there's a crew who just
wanted to be smugglers and grind out a
little bit of profit with a Jedi who is
ultimately a closeted Jedi through a
series of circumstances this will lead
to what we know as the rebellion that's
pretty cool again conceptually but my
viewpoint that I had so long ago when I
saw the first couple episodes of it
being family-friendly Star Wars
adventure for kids never really changed
in the show until the last three
episodes the last three episodes are
actually really thick they're pretty
cool
lore why is an intensity and everything
Star Wars a cool Star Wars adventure
right there that would last three
episodes of this season one pretty good
stuff leading up to it it's smuggler
stuff and jokes and it's pretty light
and part of what makes me feel that way
is all the grit that Clone Wars
surprisingly had Clone Wars actually is
there's some goes down in there it
had a good war dynamic folks get killed
I'm not saying people in Star Wars
rebels don't get killed some detonators
go off on stormtrooper stormtroopers get
shot as always remember that's
in the force awakens when Finn runs up
to that stormtrooper and just impales
him with a lightsaber I was like oh my
god I was rad that happened a lot in
Clone Wars or some dudes got impaled
with lightsabers dudes got cut down it
was awesome and they don't require
gratuitous violence in my entertainment
that's clearly animated entertainment
for first and foremost kids is on the
Disney Channel it's not lie to ourselves
that's the demographic but coming off of
that gritty violence and Clone Wars no
one got in paled with the lightsaber in
here and they could have it again I
don't require it I just can't help but
see that hey that had the guts to do it
why doesn't this like example there's a
scene where the Inquisitor who is he's
not a Sith but he's definitely trained
in the dark side of the force and he
gets done he's pretty much Bader in
the Emperor's assassin like Asajj
Ventress and Clone Wars pretty much this
guy now these two guys failed behind him
is the Inquisitor the double-sided light
saber pops out and it cuts away to this
other dude you hear slice slice and
these dudes are dead now I feel like in
Clone Wars they would have shown the
lightsaber just I threw him or well I
think he just walked forward and sliced
their heads off at neck level I know you
can't show that I'm just saying I feel
like Clone Wars had more guts than
rebels has so far and I really shouldn't
compare the later seasons of Clone Wars
to the beginning and first season of
Star Wars rebels if we wanted to be fair
I'd compare rebel season one to Clone
Wars season one in which case I would
say rebels is better it's the same world
and story leading up to it so I can't
help but see rebel season one as the
next season of Clone Wars just there are
no clones because of clone wars is over
so what else you're gonna call it rebels
15 years later in the end I couldn't
help but feel this way I was like oh
it's a crew of smugglers going up
against a big evil empire and they will
inevitably become a huge thorn in this
Empire side if I wanted to watch that I
would watch Firefly because Firefly did
that better which is a weird thing to
say because Joss Whedon was like I came
up with Firefly because I liked Han Solo
in the Millennium Falcon that smuggler
world of Star Wars the Star Wars led to
Firefly and I see rebels as Firefly
light just to circle the world we live
in that's the world because I know it
sounds like I'm bitching about Star Wars
rebels more than I intended to I just
with all the hyper run rebels finally
watch rebels I'm like okay like I said
the last three episodes were actually
really cool if you just want to skip the
last three episodes of Star Wars right
like watch the first couple episodes of
season one get to know the characters
get the introduction and then skip right
to the last three episodes of season 1 I
think you'll be fine if you want to do
that awesome that you should do that
life's too short to watch television
that might
for you the end of season 1 of rebels
actually sets up for season 2 to be
great a couple of characters show up
they're like hey we're main players now
in Star Wars rebels you're ready and I
am ready because they're cool characters
I want to see where they go
it's especially rad if you've watched
Clone Wars which is a reason you should
probably watch Clone Wars before you
watch rebels good news is rebel Caesar 2
comes out on blu-ray pretty soon so I
should have that review up for you
pretty soon so coming right off of this
I can go right into rebel season 2 and I
can say whether or not season 2 upped
its takes up it's Andy and up to
everything I like about Star Wars I
would just kind of remain the same so it
might take Star Wars rebels is a fun
family-friendly adventure the last three
episodes were cool but I see it all as
setup for season 2 which I hope is Star
Wars bad ass rig galore we'll see
alright guys so Star Wars rebels season
1 have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you